hey losers hey bud oh if it isn't the
tiny doggy caught the car I did catch
that car no everyone knows that's
impossible yeah it parked after a car no
there was no one in the car no one in
the car listen I don't even have to keep
this conversation going what I was
trying to do losers was introduce you to
my new friend Reggie he just got done
wow sorry mate welcome to the club I'm
sorry was it at least Mutual no it's
actually just the game Bridge I want you
to meet Hunter he's a therapy dog who
works in a home for dying humans which
sounds like okay kid except that he was
trained to be a police dog you almost
made it to the police squad that's
awesome yeah I I guess it's awesome the
out of my way homeboy oh sorry
about that Bubsy hunter say something
bad mate oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um hey Bubsy you got any weekend
plans what you got it still sounds
friendly yeah raw dogging your mom ah
right well I'm pretty sure she's dead
but good luck anyway Jose love those
observations
don't let him talk to you like that
you're the biggest dog here you should
eat his face off
yeah don't let the big dick fool you
he's just a gigantic